انضم الينا ايضا من كراماتسك عامر لافي
عامر اذا يبدو انها تحولت الى حرب بنا
تحتيه كيف تصف الوضع في المناطق التي
تسيطر عليها القوات الاوكرانيه في ما
يتعلق لمنى التحتيه
نعم جلال يعني هذا الموضوع ليس جديد منذ
بدايه الحرب والقوات الروسيه تركز بشكل
كبير على المدن التحتيه وانزاد هذا
التركيز وليس هنا فقط في جمباز وانما في
عموم اوكرانيا هي الان عباره عن حربنا
تحتيه كما وصفتها الشتاء همم بدا بالفعل
وهذه البلاد معروفه
بروده التخصصها الشديد وبالتالي الان وكما
تحدث الرئيس المسك اكثر من 10 ملايين
مواطن اوكراني يعانون من انقطاع الكهرباء
في هذه الظروف الصعبه وبالتالي لكن طبعا
السلطات الاوكرانيه تتحدث عن محاولاتها
دائما لتقديم الخدمات للمواطنين لجعل هذا
الشتاء اكثر دفئا ربما في وسط هذه الحرب
همم يوميا المدن هنا في مقاطعه دونيكس يتم
قصفها تقصف بشكل كبير ويوميا هناك احصائيه
لعدد القتلى والجرحى ربما لا تتناسب مع
كميه القصف جلال لان كثير ايضا من هذه
المدن هي اصلا تركها اهلها ولم يعد هناك
كثير من الناس لكن يوميا تسقط الصواريخ
والقذائف على هذه المدن نحن نتحدث عن ان
هذه الجبهه الجبهه الشرقيه هي الجبهه
الاسخن وهذا وفقا لقياده الاركان
الاوكرانيه والجديد ربما جلال هو ان هذه
الجبهه مرشحه لان تكون اسخن في الايام
القادمه لماذا الحديث هنا اليوم من قياده
الاركان ومن كثير من المراقبين العسكريين
عن ان جزء مهم من القوات الروسيه التي
كانت موجوده في خرسان وانسحبت الى الضفه
الاخرى من النهر يتم الان ارسالها الى هذه
المنطقه نعم يتم توزيعها اكثر من جبهه لكن
التركيز الروسي عندما هو على دونيس وربما
ايضا على لوغاز وبالتالي في المره في
الايام القادمه مرشحه لان تكون هذه
المنطقه اكثر سخونه هي ساخنه هي ساخنه
مواجهات ساخنه نتحدث وفقا لقياده الاركان
التي قالت انه خلال الاسبوع الماضي فقط
هناك 500 اااه اشتباك مسلح وقع في مقاطعه
دونيس وفي نهائي المختلفه اليوم في بيان
قياده الاركان الحديث عن تمكن القوات
الاوكرانيه من صد سبعه محاولات للتقدم في
دمشق ومحاولتاين في مقاطعه الغاز اذا
المعارك مستمره مستمره في عده محاور وتبقى
منذ اكثر من اسبوع المحورين الجنوبي في
ارض يبكى والشمالي في بخمول هما المحورين
الاسكن والاصعب وفقا للقوات الاوكرانيه في
الجنوب هناك وفقا لمصادر عسكريه يتحدثنا
لهم هناك تقدم نوعا ما وصفوه بالطفيف
للقوات الروسيه التي همم تمكنها ربما من
دخول قريه اوبتني وهناك محاولات جاده وقصف
مستمر يصفونه الاوكرانيين بدمار شامل
وتدمير منهجي ل- منطقه
هذه المنطقه التي تحاول قوه الروسيه دخول
اليها وواضح ان هناك خطه لمحاصره مدينه
وايضا هناك محاولات اخرى للتقدم
قريه التي قل قوات الروسيه انها سيطرت
عليها تقول القوات الاوكرانيه بانها نعم
انسحبت منها لكن همم لواء المدفعيه 72 ما
زال يقوم بقصف القوات الروسيه هناك
ويمنعها من التقدم والسيطره على هذه
المنطقه اخيرا اختم بمخبو- مخمود التي
وفقا للقوات الاوكرانيه لا يوجد اي تقدم
للقوات الروسيه على هذه المدينه التي تقصف
بشكل يومي وكما ذكرتم قبل قليل اكثر من
60% من بنيتها التحتيه اصبح مدمرا بسبب
القصف اليوم
التي همم
للموالينا لروسيا رواياتهم الخاصه فيما
يتعلق بالمعاناه هناك في دون بس
نعم مياده لربما ما يجعل هذه المناطق
الخاضعه لسيطره الموالين لروسيا والقريبه
من خط وقفه وخطا اطلاق طبعا النار خط
الجبهه الرئيسي
ما يجعلها مختلفه عن باقي المناطق التي
تشهد معارك اليوم هو ان هذه المناطق
وكما يؤكد المواليد لروسيا تتعرض لقصف
بشكل مستمر منذ عام 2014 اي منذ اندلاع
هذا الصراع التالي هناك مشاكل كثيره في
البنيه التحتيه اليوم مركز الدفاع المشترك
هنا في دنيا اسكعلنا عن مقتل مدني واحد
وجرح واربعه اخرين في قصف اوكراني استهدف
احياء عده في مدينه وكان هذا القصف غير
بعيد من هذا المكان حيث وسط مدينه استهدف
المدرسه بحسب المواليد لروسيا لكنه لم
يخلف همم هذا القصف اشتد في الحقيقه
الليله الماضيه كنا
الليله الماضيه نسمع اصوات المدفعيه
الثقيله والرجمات الصواريخ والسقوط ايضا
القذائف والانفجارات في مناطق مختلفه من
هذه المدينه هذا لربما هذه الوتيره
المتساعده في القصف لربما تعطينا صوره عن
حال الجبهات الرئيسيه خاصه هنا قرب مدينه
دمياط حيث يتحدث المولود لروسي على انهم
يحاولون ويسعون في هذه الفتره بالتحديد
التركيز على ابعاد القوات الاوكرانيه من
المحيط مدينه دنياسكم هذا ايضا ما يفسر
همم تقدمهم في محيط المطار وسيطرته على
بلده اوبو
والان تجري معارك كما قال الزميل في بلده
مايسكا وهي احنا اهم البلدات التي يقولون
بانها ستمهد لهم الطريق نحو هدفهم الاول
وهو مدينه افدي افكا القريبه من دنيا
اسكاليوم همم وسائل الاعلام الروسيه اتهمت
القوات الاوكرانيه دي ما قالت انه اعدامات
ميدانيه نفذتها في حق الجنود وعسكريين روس
في مقاطعه لوغانس بثت صورا قالت انها
مسربه لتنفيذ تلك
الاعدامات المدنيه وتحديدا كما قال موقع
ريباره العسكري الروسي المتخصص حدث هذه
الاعدامات حدثت في بلده ماكيفكا التي
سيطرت عليها القوات الاوكرانيه الاسبوع
الماضي ذلك المحور ايضا في الحقيقه يشهد
معارك محتدمه ومحاولات المتكرره للقوات
الوكرانيه من اجل تقدم لقطع الطريق الطريق
الدعم العسكري الرئيسي في تلك المنطقه
الرابط بين كريمينا وصبا طبعا القوات
الروسيه تقول بانها تصب كل تلك الهجمات
وايضا هجمات اخرى في كل من محاور زابا
روجيا وايضا جنوب مدينه دنياز كالحديث
الان همم في الحقيقه هو ما
التسبيه المواليد لروسيا كثيرا في اللون
الاخيره بشان سعي اوكراني ودفع همم القوات
الاوكرانيه بمزيد من الدعم وايضا القوات
باتجاه محور زبوجيا الذي ايضا والى جانب
دنيا يسكن مرشح لان يكون طبعا في صداره
الاحداث هنا وان تكون هناك المعارك همم
شديده بعد طبعا الانسحاب من الضفه اليمنى
تورس